des Barbies en fauteuil atteinte de
vitiligo avec une prothèse aujourd'hui
place à la différence avec 175 modèles
et 26 couleurs de peau rejoins elle est
super bien pas de doute et Léonore est
enchanté par la poupée dont elle a été
nommée ambassadrice il s'agit d'une
Barbie atteinte comme elle de trisomie
21 avec son torse plus long ses yeux en
amande et ses couleurs vives elle vient
étoffer les 175 modèles déjà existants
et permet ainsi une meilleure inclusion
dès le plus jeune âge elle a aussi une
taille plus petite que la Barbie
traditionnelle un buste plus long et
quand vous regardez ces jambes et bien
vous voyez qu'elle a ce qu'on appelle
des orthèses tibiales c'est ce qu'on
certains enfants porteurs de la trisomie
21 ça leur permet de soutenir leur pied
et leurs chevilles c'est une grande
fierté
à l'enfant
c'est des enfants qui vont manipuler une
poupée différente qui vont toucher la
différence en fait et je pense que ça va
ouvrir déjà le regard il y a eu quand
même des moqueries certaines personnes
qui estiment que c'est ce soumettre aux
injonctions communautaires venues des
États-Unis mais dans le même temps il y
a aussi des enfants voilà en situation
de handicap qui sont très heureux et des
parents qui soutiennent ça les parents
de ses enfants là autant autant je ne
nie pas la réalité de la trisomie 21 et
le drame que ça peut poser pour les
parents mais pourquoi les jouets
doivent-ils suivre si vous voulez une
certaine tendance il faut être
politiquement correct il faut bien sûr
un pourcentage de noir en pourcentage de
handicapés un pourcentage moi je pense
qu'il faut garder c'est des jouets pour
enfants il faut garder l'innocence aux
enfants
Thomas vous êtes prêts
qui a une trisomie 21 va lui donner on
va lui montrer sa propre représentation
pas du tout non alors moi je vais je
vais peut-être choquer mais je veux dire
si on continue comme ça pourquoi pas une
poupée trans mais non mais parce que
je veux dire
[Rires]
c'est une sorte de suivisme si vous
voulez sur certaines tendances
aujourd'hui du politiquement correct moi
je pense qu'il faut garder un certain
conservatisme au moins sur l'innocence
des enfants Perrine il est bête comme
ses pieds mais ça lui fait une belle
jambe oui les morts n'ont plus de vie
privée Gaspard voilà une des choses que
j'ai apprises écrivez-vous avant de
raconter une scène qui paraît si
réaliste de jeunes filles qui vous
demandent de vous pousser
oui oui
j'étais encore la semaine dernière par
la chaise avec mon fils et on a eu
encore des anecdotes comme ça elle vous
demandait de vous pousser pour décaler
une photo pour faire une photo d'elle
avec la tombe il s'agit de Paco Rabanne
exactement
[Applaudissements]
il annoncé l'apocalypse pour le jour de
l'éclipse totale du 11 août à Paris et
quelques villes du Gers qui tremblait de
voir la station Mir s'écraser puis
finalement il s'est rien passé on le
saurait forcément donc du coup après il
a présenté c'est ses excuses et il nous
a quitté en février dernier et ça non
plus il avait pas vu venir la merde
aussi a été prise à partie par une des
fans
de votre ancien compagnon
c'était c'était aussi au Père Lachaise
et la dame disait mais moi je suis sa
plus grande fan qui êtes-vous pour
nettoyer la tombe je suis sa mère et
donc voilà on a on sait pas après on
on peut en rire parce que c'est ça
paraît complètement grotesque
aujourd'hui on se met tellement la
pression on passe notre temps à se
demander est-ce que je suis une bonne
mère une bonne collègue je pense qu'il
faut se poser un peu et le bien-être
permet de se reconnecter avec son propre
corps
en 2008 elle lance gooop un site devant
en ligne un business évalue aujourd'hui
à 200 millions d'euros mais ce succès va
faire polémique la star met en vente des
produits étonnants comme cette bouteille
de répulsif avant pire ou des bougies au
parfum intime c'est le légume du soleil
pourquoi premièrement parce qu'il est
très peu calorique en fait c'est
l'Allier minceur de l'été 30 kcal pour
100 g soit 3 fois moins que le petit
pois ou la pomme de terre
[Applaudissements]
rectal je sais ça paraît très bizarre
mais ça a été très utile
de l'ozone introduit dans l'anus oui
vous avez bien entendu une pratique sans
patte scientifique qui n'existe pas en
France le docteur Elise Pomaret a bien
voulu nous éclairer le but c'est de
désinfecter de purifier le rectum ou
voilà mais c'est illusoire
baisser sa vitre éviter de faire pareil
en sa pote mal interprétée
toi aussi tu as pété
je vous ai pas présenté Ophélie qui est
avec nous bonjour
[Rires]
des Coralie nous c'est Mauricette
Thérèse Dédé quoi c'est pour ça que je
suis allongé des personnes ange Macron
vous avez une petite info assez
extraordinaire qui nous vient en Macron
[Rires]
Philippe Lavil revient avec un album et
des reprises de ses plus grands tubes
elle fait l'amour en mer elle aime faire
la grand-mère
et elle le fait aussi
c'est vrai que je lève de moins en moins
la jambe et Dieu sait que j'ai commencé
dans ce métier comme ça c'est
qu'il y a des gens qui ont couché pour
réussir moi j'essaye de réussir pour
coucher moi
balance
je reste quand même pour
il y a beaucoup de possibilités
pensez à Daniel Balavoine
je reste quand même pour ton
bonsoir créer là attention à certains
desserts qui ont la mousse un petit peu
à l'air
je me suis retenu je veux dire je te
jure je me sens mieux
j'ai un petit peu la mousse à l'air
ça sera dans le bêtisier ça